Should patients be the aggregation point for all their health data?
Should they contribute data they have documented or recorded using devices and apps?
Should they have access to their physicians notes,
and even the ability to suggest corrections?
Will their use of personal technologies engage them and lead to better outcomes?
These are some of the key questions,
and potential benefits that arise from the concept of a personal health record, or PHR.
The term first appeared in a 1978 paper,
but it was really not practical until around
2000 with the dramatic decline in the cost of computing,
and the increasing availability of the Internet.
Of course the almost universal use of
smartphones provides a near ideal ubiquitous PHR platform.
The original idea was a patient maintained record,
but you can see from these questions it's scope is expanding in our connected world.
Today the Markle Foundation's Connecting for Health initiative
defines a personal health record as quote,
an electronic application through which individuals can access, manage,
and share their health information,
and that of others for whom they are authorized.
In a private, secure,
and confidential environment, end quote.